in the last 24 hours we've seen YouTube
Reddit and twitch takes some major steps
to enforce their Terms of Service and
weed out what they believe to be hateful
content content that encourages violence
content that violates their Terms of
Service and once again conservatives are
going absolutely cuckoo for cocoa puffs
as I like to say claiming that this is
all about targeting conservatives that
every platform on the Internet
other than what's that new one parlor or
something like that arguing that every
platform on the Internet are just about
has anti conservative bias
everybody's biased against conservatives
now this may be a tough pill to swallow
for the American right but most
political violence is right-wing and I'm
gonna get to the details of that later
and I know like you know they talk about
anti feh and Tifa has never killed
anyone to my knowledge eco-terrorism
right like you you it's not untrue that
we have seen political violence from the
left but the vast majority of the
political violence and the violent
rhetoric is on the right that's just the
reality and that means that if you have
a policy as a platform which says we
don't allow violent rhetoric we don't
allow encouraging violence against
groups of people based on membership in
a protected class if you enforce those
policies by definition you're going to
sweep up more conservatives now if the
policy was one that either implicitly or
explicitly targeted a protected class
based on race nationality etc they might
have a case but what you have here is
merely a reflection of the reality that
the vast majority of violent language
violent rhetoric and actual violence is
on the right now I'm gonna get to that a
little bit later first what happened who
was banned number one Donald Trump's own
twitch channel was temporarily suspended
hateful content is not allowed on Twitch
the Trump twitch channel broadcast that
old speech Trump made about when Mexico
sends us its people there
not sending their best they're sending
you know rapists and drug addicts and
whatever they rebroadcast that also they
broadcast from Tulsa Oklahoma rally for
a week or two ago and they're also Trump
told this story about it's one o'clock
in the morning and a bad hombre as
Donald Trump likes to say of course the
the word is pronounced hombre
but as Trump says hombre you call 911
this kind of like violent imagery about
Hispanics that also apparently violating
Twitch's policies and twich says this
violated Terms of Service and good for
them I mean there's absolutely no
controversy there whatsoever
reddit banned a controversial pro Trump
subreddit called the Donald it's a
cesspool of some of the worst pro Trump
propaganda around and reddit said that
subreddit promotes hate based on
identity or vulnerability they regularly
post spam as well as malicious attempts
to interfere with other reddit
communities and thus the donald
subreddit was caught up in the ban also
by the way it wasn't only the right in
this case the ostensibly left-wing
subreddit chapo chapo Chapo I don't even
know Trap House was also caught up in it
and then sort of like the really big
news over on YouTube YouTube has banned
conspiracy theorist stefan molyneux
white nationalists david duke white
nationalists Richard Spencer and some
others the reason there according to
youtube is that all of those channels
are regularly violating hate speech
policy and policies that protect
specific classes of people from targeted
discriminations the fond Molyneux
actually posted a hilarious tweet in
response to this where he said quote
YouTube just suspended the largest
philosophy conversation the world has
ever known
philosophy yeah that's a hilarious way
to describe it but needless to say this
is happening so first of all really
Trump should probably be banned from
I mean if you just want to do a cold
unbiased reading of twitches of
Twitter's policies Trump shared you know
the white power video on Sunday and
deleted it
Trump regularly encourages the bullying
of individuals on Twitter
clearly Trump violates Twitter's
guidelines and if Twitter was to take
those seriously Trump would have been
banned that hasn't happened important to
know number number two you're seeing all
of the same people who insist companies
should be allowed to do whatever nobody
should be forced to bake a cake for a
gay wedding all of those same people are
now saying the government should force
twitch YouTube reddit whatever those
companies should be forced to allow
other peoples hate speech to exist there
now they'll come back and say hate
speech is in the eye of the beholder
okay well you don't run YouTube YouTube
runs YouTube so what matters is what is
hate speech from the perspective of
YouTube now I've sometimes suffered at
the hand of YouTube's whims you all know
that when it came to D monetization on a
number of different issues when it came
to YouTube couldn't tell the difference
between an actual white nationalist
Channel versus me criticizing white
nationalism like listen I I don't
pretend that I am NOT pushing for what
would always be best for me I may not
agree with YouTube's decisions but how
do you say YouTube must be forced to
publish what they believe to be hate
speech my personal view is that more
speech is generally better than less
speech and yet how can these companies
not have Terms of Service and be allowed
to enforce them they can and they are
enforcing them now to go back to what I
said at the beginning the reality is
that most political violence and hateful
rhetoric is on the right it doesn't mean
that it doesn't exist on the left I know
people like to talk about an Tifa etc
but we have to talk about proportion
look at the anti-defamation league's
report on murder and extremism in 2019
76%
of politically murders resulting from
political extremism 76% were
right-wingers of various flavors 3% were
left wingers including anarchists and
black nationalists I think there's a
debate to be had over whether black
nationalism is really on the left I
would argue it's probably not but okay
and then 20% were Islamic extremists and
again there's debate over whether
Islamic extremists are on the left or
right I believe they're on the right
when you believe that your religion
should be the law of the land and you're
willing to kill over your religious
beliefs that's not any kind of left-wing
belief that I've ever seen but
regardless these are not small margins
the numbers are ultra clear so when
YouTube or twitch or whoever say we're
gonna sweep up and enforce our policy
when it comes to violent rhetoric
targeting of people based on identity
etc of course more right-wingers are
going to be caught in it because that
type of content is disproportionately
coming from that side of the political
spectrum if you agree with me if you
disagree with me I want to hear from you
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and I hope
that you've subscribed to the free daily
audio podcast that we put out every
single day it's free my friends
completely free it's on Spotify iTunes
stitcher google play and all of your
favorite podcast apps privacy comm is
one of our sponsors and they're giving
you $5.00 just for using their free
service at privacy comm slash Pakman
privacies of service I've been using for
a while now I love it it saves me a
bunch of headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works
when you pay for something online or
over the phone instead of exposing your
real credit card number privacy lets you
generate virtual card numbers the
payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you
want I especially loved it for free
trials where you need to give a credit
card number because I can destroy the
virtual card number as soon as I give it
to the company and I know I won't be
charged in the future if you're ordering
food over the phone why do I need to
give a restaurant my real card number I
don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are your real credit card
number is protected from the data
breaches that happen unfortunately more
often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy comm slash Pakman